i
[Música]
ah
un grupo de tres investigadores dos de
ellos estadounidenses alterase y uno de
ellos británico hatton fueron los
ganadores del premio nobel de medicina
por sus investigaciones frente a la
hepatitis se lograron descubrir un virus
que es la causa común de la hepatitis
crónica y la organización del premio
nobel aseguró que este es un logro
histórico en la batalla contra
enfermedades virales se espera que esta
semana también el premio nobel sea
otorgado para otras categorías como
física química literatura y paz
[Música]
rusia está trabajando ya en la segunda
vacuna rusa que ha sido encargada al
laboratorio vector situado en la región
de siberia mientras tanto siguen
añadiendo países a la lista de
interesados en probar la primera vacuna
rusa la llamada es putin 5 y sabemos que
venezuela ha recibido hace unos días el
pasado viernes las primeras 2.000 dosis
de esta vacuna con lo cual va a poder
participar en la famosa fase 3 la fase
final para probar este medicamento que
recordemos fue presentado el pasado 15
de agosto por los científicos rusos y
fue criticado en un primer momento
porque las pruebas habían sido muy
rápidas y se conocían pocas cosas de
este fármaco sin embargo rusia asegura
que la vacuna es segura y que además
ofrece una protección duradera de hecho
algunas empresas aquí en moscú ya están
distribuyendo las primeras dosis a sus
trabajadores y animándoles a que la
prueben para poder ir frenando poco a
poco la expansión del coronavirus en
rúsia
[Música]
el doctor vicente ver es ven como
director del instituto finlay de la
habana ofrece una actualización acerca
de los ensayos clínicos de soberana 1 el
primer candidato vacunal cubano contra
la cob y 19 voluntarios cubanos ya van a
recibir la segunda dosis de la vacuna al
referirse a la seguridad de los
candidatos vacunales subrayó que se
basan en plataformas tecnológicas de
vacunas que ya existen y ya se han
probado en millones de dosis tras
aplicar la segunda dosis de soberana 1
en 40 voluntarios los resultados
confirman que los efectos adversos son
mínimos
el investigador aseveró que el equipo de
trabajo aspira a avanzar de manera
decisiva en los estudios referente a la
respuesta inmune antes de que termine el
presente año y mantiene el propósito de
empezar a vacunar a toda la población
cubana durante el primer semestre de